ces images de villes fantômes ravive le
traumatisme de la première vague de
coronavirus qui avait ébranlé la chine
il ya deux ans shanghai semble vidé de
ses 25 millions d'habitants qui
subissait un confinement très stricte
depuis deux semaines actuellement je
suis confiné sur la campus donc c'est
complètement impossible de sortir du
campus les portes d'accès du campus ont
complètement barré impossibilité totale
de sortir que ce soit pour aller à
l'épicerie ou même pour avoir des soins
guillaume marois vie sur limoges campus
de l'université de shanghai comme des
dizaines de milliers d'étudiants et
d'enseignants ils sont confinés dans
leur chambre depuis six semaines en
raison d'une éclosion sur le campus
début mars il ya une certaine anxiété ou
si au niveau de kasséré qu'on est
positif puisqu'il ya les gens positifs
sont envoyés dans les cadres quarantaine
ou que nos têtes cinq dix minutes quinze
mille personnes sont entassées dans les
amphithéâtres où dans les arénas comme
les épiceries et les marchés sont fermés
depuis plus de deux semaines une partie
de la population commence à avoir faim
et craint de manquer de nourriture
je pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de
gens qui crèvent de faim à shanghai en
ce moment mais il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont des difficultés ou qu'ils
doivent manger du riz blanc ou des
nouilles instantanées tous les jours
donc lire on a vu le jour en jour la
protestation là dessus montez y compris
parfois des altercations avec avec la
police ou avec des gardiens
des gens ici un marché c'est la moitié
des habitants de shanghai n'ont eu que
quelques heures pour faire des
provisions avant d'être confiné beaucoup
ont manqué de nourriture avant que la
distribution de rations ne s'organise
dans les quartiers
certains sont sortis pour en trouver ou
pour manifester
d'autres expriment leur colère du balcon
de leur appartement
c'est shanghai les gens crient dit
l'homme qui a fini cette vidéo tu
regardes lancera dans la tradition ça a
commencé par quelques personnes mettant
tout le monde crie parce qu'on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe personne ne sait
quand ça va finir
les autorités ne se contente pas de
distribuer des tests rapides tous les
habitants de shanghai doivent passer un
test pcr haut doubs trois jours le
québécois car le broc et bénévole dans
l'équipe de dépistage de son quartier je
racontais voisins et nos puits en
recevoir parce que ma part vidéo parce
que parce que comme vous savez en étant
un vrai look terme c'est-à-dire condé on
est confiné à la maison l'ingénieur et
homme d'affaires qui parle couramment
mandarin sent la colère des chinois
qu'ils côtoient comme bénévole ronald
fonds lancé des gens beaucoup de gens
font des achats en ligne de nourriture
ok puis en a qui reçoit mais alors
qu'ils reçoivent pas il y en a qui
disent qu'ils sont pour recevoir
quartier finalement c'est l'eau qui vole
la nourriture et comme l'essai sur bar
de la rue à la à la porte car si c'est
aussi difficile pour les employeurs qui
doivent faire des mises à pied massives
les activités manufacturières de carl
bros qui fabrique des composantes
électroniques son temps pour vous
l'usiné fermée qui accueillait chaque
école qui fabrique l'entrepôt aussi
fermé dans coeur mais on est à l'arrêt
total depuis
ça va faire dix jours bien sûr ça a un
impact économique très fort x a un
impact sur l'emploi évidemment tous les
employés des services la restauration le
tourisme le divertissement sont
complètement dévastée
lundis soirs des résidents ont célébré
leur liberté retrouvée après une
première baisse du nombre de cas à
shanghai depuis plus d'un mois les
autorités ont des confiné un premier
complexe résidentiel ceux qui sont
libérés dans les rues sont libérés dans
une ville fantôme parce que tous les
tous les magasins sont fermés et ils
n'ont le droit d'aller paie ici sophie
langlois radio canada montréal